-Il partage avec François Bayrou
un attachement
pour le même territoire
et une amitié de plus de 40 ans.
Mon invité a été macroniste
avant l'heure,
centriste dans l'âme,
il préside le groupe MoDem
à l'Assemblée avec un style unique,
parfois déroutant.
Générique
...
Bonjour, Jean-Paul Mattei.
-Bonjour.
-On attend d'un président de groupe
qu'il fasse régner
l'ordre dans ses rangs sauf que,
avec vous, c'est parfois l'inverse
qui se produit,
notamment au débat budgétaire 2022.
Vous menez la fronde
contre le gouvernement
avec un amendement pour taxer
les super-dividendes
des grandes entreprises.
Voici ceux qui ont
pris la parole dans l'hémicycle
pour vous soutenir.
-On va voter l'amendement
de notre collègue,
il prend le pognon
là où il faut le prendre
pour le donner là où y en a besoin.
-Je crois que c'est
une mesure de bon sens,
qui devrait rassembler
largement sur ces bancs.
Nous voterons ce dispositif.
-C'est un amendement
très raisonnable,
très constructif,
qui peut rassembler tout le monde
pour avancer sur un sujet
qui fera du bien à la démocratie
et à la justice fiscale.
-Résultat du scrutin.
L'Assemblée nationale a adopté.
-On vient de voir
Sébastien Jumel
pour le PC,
Manuel Bompard
pour LFI et Jean-Philippe Tanguy
pour le RN.
Tous ont voté votre amendement
contre l'avis du gouvernement.
Est-ce que vous êtes vraiment
dans votre rôle de président
de groupe de la majorité
quand vous faites cela ?
-Suis-je dans mon rôle ?
En tout cas,
j'ai une forte conviction
sur cette mesure,
qui est un signe, comme je l'ai dit,
dans l'hémicycle,
il s'agissait pas
d'un grand soir fiscal
mais simplement d'une mesure
qui, pour moi, était de bon sens.
Alors, effectivement,
j'ai peut-être pas pris conscience
de mon rôle
de président de groupe,
à ce moment-là, mais je pense
que mon groupe était derrière,
d'ailleurs, il a voté,
ils ont tous voté l'amendement.
-Vous dites pas pris conscience,
y a peut-être un mea culpa
a posteriori ?
-Non, je cherchais pas un coup
politique.
Pour moi, il était important
d'envoyer un petit signe,
la société est un peu crispée
et je trouvais qu'il allait
dans le bon sens,
l'ensemble des intervenants
le souligne.
J'ai pas cherché à faire un coup,
j'ai simplement voulu
que l'on vote une mesure
pour moi de bon sens.
-Vous comprenez qu'une partie
de la majorité vous considère
comme un enquiquineur,
voire comme un dangereux
gauchiste,
vous en avez fait d'autres,
des coups comme ça sur la fiscalité,
votre domaine de prédilection.
-Non, mais moi,
je suis un profond libéral
et je pense qu'il peut y avoir
des mesures de justice fiscale
qui accompagnent.
Est-ce que c'est de gauche,
de droite ?
Non, c'est du bon sens.
J'envoyais un signe et,
encore une fois,
je cherchais pas à jouer
les francs-tireurs,
ou les frondeurs,
mais simplement apporter
ma pierre au débat budgétaire,
qui avait besoin
de respirer et d'envoyer
quelques signes,
notamment aux gens
qui galèrent un peu.
-Y a eu les super-dividendes
mais aussi les rachats d'actions
par les grosses entreprises
ou la niche fiscale d'Airbnb.
Vous avez porté des mesures
plébiscitées par la gauche.
Vous êtes au courant
de vos différents surnoms ?
-J'en ai entendu quelques-uns,
je crois qu'on m'a traité
de camarade Mattei,
je crois que c'est Jumel.
-Tout à fait, Sébastien Jumel.
-Euh de...
-Notaire révolutionnaire ?
-Notaire révolutionnaire, voilà.
-Ou "l'insoumattei",
Hadrien Clouet.
-Y a même un article
qui m'a traité de punk.
-Et les écologistes
ont imprimé des tee-shirts
à votre effigie.
-C'est ce qu'on m'a dit,
je les ai pas vus,
mais c'est ce qu'on m'a dit.
-Star des députés de gauche ?
-Je cherche pas du tout ça,
franchement.
Je cherche simplement
à montrer qu'on peut dialoguer
et trouver des points d'atterrissage
sur certains sujets.
Mais je ne rêve pas,
je sais bien que,
même si ces mesures
avaient été adoptées,
c'est pas pour autant que la gauche
aurait voté le projet
de loi de finances.
Effectivement,
président de groupe,
le mandat précédent,
j'étais pas président de groupe,
et j'ai porté des amendements,
sur l'augmentation de la flat tax,
et ça a fait moins de bruit.
-Vous avez travaillé
avec des députés de gauche,
notamment avec Eric Coquerel,
pas encore président
de la commission des finances,
mais c'était aussi
son domaine de prédilection.
Cette opposition frontale entre LFI
et le gouvernement,
c'est du spectacle ?
Il serait possible
de trouver des accords,
ponctuellement, avec LFI ?
-Je pense qu'on peut trouver
avec certains membres de LFI
des points d'atterrissage
sur certains sujets.
On avait, avec Eric Coquerel,
déposé un amendement en commun
sur le fait qu'un dirigeant
de grande entreprise française
paie ses impôts en France,
un peu en écho à ce qui s'était
passé avec Carlos Ghosn,
on a trouvé des compromis.
-Y a une part de mise en scène
de la politique ?
-Oui, il est certain que, moi,
je suis dans l'hémicycle
comme à l'extérieur,
je peux difficilement
changer de style,
pour moi, c'est compliqué
d'avoir un autre style
dans l'hémicycle et à l'extérieur.
Vous avez des députés
qui sont un peu en scène,
qui font des capsules vidéo, voilà,
moi, je cherche pas ça,
je suis pas un fana
de la politique spectacle,
mais attention,
je pense qu'un Parlement parle,
on débat et qu'il faut pas
critiquer les grandes
envolées lyriques,
je pense qu'elles sont nécessaires
au débat parlementaire,
c'est que je suis un peu
moins sur ce style,
chacun a sa façon
de voir les choses.
-Autre chose fait de vous
un président de groupe
assez iconoclaste :
vous êtes arrivé
à ce poste "par hasard".
C'est possible de devenir chef,
en politique, par hasard ?
-Alors, je m'étais pas préparé
à être président de groupe.
Moi, le dernier quinquennat,
j'ai fait un mandat assez assidu,
je travaillais
en commission des finances,
passionné par tout ça,
j'étais vice-président
du groupe MoDem, à l'époque,
il s'appelait pas Démocrate,
MoDem et Indépendants.
Il se trouve que Patrick Mignola,
qui avait pris la suite
de Marc Fesneau,
a été battu, donc, en 2022,
aux élections législatives,
et donc, certains de mes collègues
ont souhaité que je me présente,
j'ai présenté ma candidature
et j'ai été élu
à la présidence de ce groupe
et je suis totalement investi
dans ce poste.
Le hasard s'est transformé
en détermination.
-Vous avez une conception
particulière de votre rôle,
vous dites rôle d'animateur,
mettre de la rondeur
dans les relations,
vous êtes "le tonton du groupe,
"le paternel attentif".
C'est-à-dire que,
pour vous,
ce poste de président de groupe
n'est pas un poste politique ?
-C'est un poste politique,
mais pas fait pour me voir, moi.
Mon but, c'est d'être créatif
et je pense que,
la créativité,
vous l'avez à travers
des femmes et des hommes qui ont
tous des talents, et donc, mon rôle
est de faire émerger ces talents,
qu'ils soient mis en avant,
et pas me mettre, moi, en avant,
c'est pas mon rôle.
-J'ai noté un autre point :
vous dressez un parallèle
entre les raisons
qui vous ont fait choisir
la profession de notaire
et qui vous ont fait
vous engager en politique :
c'est pour mettre les gens d'accord.
-Oui, moi, j'adore le compromis.
Je pense que...
-Et un notaire, c'est pareil ?
-Ah oui, un notaire,
c'est quelqu'un qui passe
sa vie à mettre
les gens d'accord,
les partages de famille,
les conflits de voisins,
on est là pour apaiser,
donc c'est facile,
ensuite, dans votre vie politique,
notamment quand j'étais maire,
d'avoir cette action de compromis,
mettre les gens d'accord,
il faut qu'on aboutisse,
qu'on soit d'accord.
-Vous vous êtes engagé
en politique
aussi pour soutenir
une personne précise,
vous expliquez avoir flashé
pour Giscard, alors, en terminale,
vous êtes si passionné
que votre mère est persuadée
que c'est à cause de lui
que vous loupez votre bac.
-Absolument, ma mère,
qui n'est plus de ce monde,
m'avait reproché d'être très engagé,
effectivement, à l'époque,
cet homme m'a séduit,
sa façon de faire
de la politique un peu hors normes.
Vous savez, quand je vois ce que,
le parcours du président Macron,
bah, Valéry Giscard d'Estaing,
peut-être un peu plus
d'antériorité en politique,
mais il est arrivé comme ça.
Et on avait pas le droit de vote,
en 74, le droit de vote
est à 21 ans,
j'avais pas le droit de vote,
voilà, je me suis engagé,
je me suis passionné
pour cette cause,
et, effectivement, j'ai un peu
délaissé mon travail en terminale.
-Vous avez pris des responsabilités
dans le mouvement
des jeunes giscardiens,
Génération Sociale et Libérale,
vous avez la carte de membre
presque tout le temps sur vous.
-Je peux vous la sortir.
-Elle est sur vous ?
-Je crois que je l'ai, là.
Je la porte pas tout le temps,
mais comme il y avait l'émission,
je l'ai trouvée
en rangeant mes archives,
j'ai trouvé sympa...
Alors, vous savez,
Génération Sociale et Libérale,
c'est tout à fait
dans ma ligne aujourd'hui,
libérale,
humaniste, sociale, voilà.
-A la fac de Pau, vous avez monté
un syndicat étudiant, la Garbure.
-La Garbure étudiante.
-Avec pour objectif
de rassembler des gens
de sensibilités diverses.
En montant ensuite votre liste
pour devenir maire de Ger en 2001,
vous êtes allé chercher des gens
de tous les bords politiques,
droite et gauche.
Le macronisme,
c'est juste du mattéisme.
-Oui, on va rester à sa place.
J'ai eu cette chance d'être
à la tête d'une commune
de 2000 habitants
pendant 16 ans avec effectivement
des gens de tous les bords.
Au moment du mariage pour tous,
par exemple, y a eu un peu
de crispation dans mon équipe,
mais tout ça s'est apaisé.
On faisait des choses,
avec des conceptions différentes,
on faisait des choses,
c'est une très belle expérience,
ça fonctionne, ça peut fonctionner,
et je rêverais
qu'on y arrive à l'Assemblée.
-Une autre personne
que Giscard a compté,
c'est François Bayrou,
vous le connaissez depuis 1976,
il était présent
à votre mariage,
il vous a demandé d'être
son suppléant en 2012
à la législative perdue à Pau,
il vous dit de vous présenter
en 2017 aux législatives.
Quelle est la nature
de votre relation
politique avec lui ?
Dans la majorité, certains,
quand vous parlez,
entendent François Bayrou.
Un responsable de la majorité
disait anonymement dans le Figaro :
"Jean-Paul Mattei,
c'est la voix de son maître."
-François Bayrou
m'appelle rarement pour me dire
de faire ci ou ça.
On est pas du tout dans cet échange.
On se voit, on se rencontre,
mais je ne reçois pas de consignes.
D'ailleurs,
j'aurais du mal à les accepter,
non pas que ça m'agacerait vite,
je suis pas sous curatelle
ou tutelle.
J'ai une profonde admiration
pour le personnage,
son parcours, une forte amitié,
un fort respect, voilà,
mais on est pas dans une relation
du maître, la voix de son maître,
du tout, je le ressens pas comme ça
et je pense qu'il a
la même vision des choses.
-On va passer à notre quiz,
je vous explique le principe,
je commence des phrases
et vous les complétez.
-Je sais pas si je saurai faire.
-C'est très simple.
A chaque fois qu'on m'appelle
"Jean-François" Mattei ?
Justement, comme moi.
-Oui, je pense au ministre
de la Santé...
-Ca vous agace ?
-Non, pas vraiment,
c'était quelqu'un de respectable,
que je connais pas.
-Il a été centriste.
-Il a un beau parcours,
voilà, non, au contraire,
bon, vous savez, Mattei,
c'est un nom assez courant en Corse,
mais ça ne me vexe pas,
ça ne me crispe pas
et j'ai beaucoup d'admiration
pour son parcours.
-Ma dernière discussion
en tête à tête
avec Bruno Le Maire ?
-Ca remonte à la semaine dernière,
au congrès des maires, vous savez,
il avait fait un pot,
donc on a échangé et...
-Ca s'est bien passé ?
Vous avez été conflit
plusieurs fois.
-Je pense qu'il y a un respect
mutuel,
Bruno Le Maire est
un ministre des Finances courageux,
avec un grand talent,
je partage pas
tout à fait sa vision,
je le trouve un peu raide,
mais j'ai pas ses contraintes.
Moi, je suis dans mon rôle
de législateur
et lui dans son rôle
de ministre des Finances.
-Si je devais choisir un député
avec qui traverser l'Atlantique
à la voile ?
Car vous êtes fan de voile.
-Alors...
Y aurait soit Jimmy Pahun.
-Ah bah oui,
ancien skippeur !
-Il sait faire.
Et pourquoi pas Coquerel ?
-Eh oui,
c'est ce que j'avais en tête,
il a organisé
des courses transatlantiques
à la voile.
-Bien sûr.
-Les trois ensemble ?
-Ce serait bien.
-Merci beaucoup,
Jean-Paul Mattei, d'être venu.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...